hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry today
we're finally gonna be doing our
Avengers age of Ultron spoiler talk
about it's about time we're standing
today why because this has been hung
here for a long time why I'm gonna get
to use it before we go into this I did
want to actually clear some things up
clear the air a little bit too much bad
marijuana spreading around getting
people the wrong thoughts setting more
Jews I feel like when people saw my
first review of this my non-spoiler
review that everyone thought that I
[ __ ] hated the film cuz I know what
happens they watch the first like minute
or two of my review and then they go
[ __ ] you I disagree and then they turn
off the computer not here the rest a
wreck yeah they all have IBS and that's
our biggest problem ok the main thing I
got crap for was I said there's mics I
watched this beforehand to make sure
this is what I said I said I feel like
the phone could have used a bit more
humor and everyone was like no humour
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you this
film is so much humor and I was like
yeah I know I said he beat more humour
here's the other thing some people were
like yeah it was really dark could use a
little bit more humor but then these
other guys didn't [ __ ] get it and it
was like never a medium I never met saw
someone who was like this one with the
right balance everyone was like either I
agree or it had too much humor and that
especially comes from their point of
view towards Ultron another thing I
could relapse about this all Ultron
situation I said one thing in my review
and everyone took it the wrong way I
said if they could defeat a god then I
totally believe they can defeat
artificial intelligence and now everyone
was like what are you talking about Loki
sucks Oh John was [ __ ] scared and I
seen the review that Ultron scary and I
said right then and there even though I
didn't believe they win Ultron still
scared me Loki didn't scare me I mean I
artificial intelligence it's like more
advanced than
like they just created another human
he's got like the entire capability of
the internet all weapons on her yeah
like yeah he's got everything at his
disposal I mean don't get me wrong like
Loki was a God so I was under this
impression that like okay he has like
some form of super powers as opposed to
Ultron but he does have his Ultron has
his own version of superpowers that do
work you know part of what makes Ultron
so [ __ ] scary is that you know some
people are really complaining about the
fact that like physically he was able to
be defeated physically almost every
single time he would just fall apart
but even though ice I felt that way at
first the more I thought about I was
like wait a minute though if he gets
defeated he just hops into another body
yeah builds another whatever nope
because he he has access to the globe at
one point Ultron
smashes himself with a new body yeah
yeah what a mid sentence or some [ __ ]
Ultron is terrifying I thought he was
more interesting to watch them Loki I
mean he's a different kind of guy Wade
also it's like it's the first time we've
seen him to see Loki like I liked him
and he was cool but I wasn't ever
actually scared of him he was fun to
watch he was a lot of fun to watch yeah
and Ultron had a cool level of terror
and fun I liked his personality you know
a lot of people don't dig it I thought
it was really cool
because it was neat to see an AI mish
like an AI with such a different kind of
personality the trailers sort of showed
Ultron as I am just your typical
menacing robot who doesn't like humans
anymore but you see him know I'm like
this guy he's kind of [ __ ] sense of
humor he came from Tony Stark and that's
clear you know every lucky one I
appreciate when people give a villain a
sense of humor because we get so many
villains who are only driven by this one
purpose and yeah like humanity's I guess
the wrong word but it gives him a
personality which is kind of refreshing
a villain who cracks jokes clearly isn't
that concern so that's even scarier to
me and that's part of what makes him
even feel more like artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
supposed to be a robot that's come to
life that's what makes the first
offender so yeah
that's what makes the first Avengers
work so well is because they gave them
all humor you know you hear Avengers and
you're like they're all coming together
badass superheroes last thing you expect
us to laugh a lot yeah but that brings
or life to it and this one to the
characters still had their human I said
it was a lot more serious than the first
one it's a lot darker but that doesn't
mean there's no humor there the humor
comes through interaction with
characters Tony Stark still really had
it a lot you know if anyone never lost
it it was him no matter how big Tony
started over it's such a form of defense
mechanism for me like he has to use it
and Hawkeye that really amped up his
jokes get a lot of creppy crack a lot of
one-liners well he was more self-aware
he's kind of the rock that holds the
team together in this room Hawkeye
really funny like what they did with his
character I like that we got to meet his
wife and kids add a lot of dimension to
him and I was wondering this like when
the movie was done OHS I was wondering
this and then Joss Whedon talked about
an interview I thought like Hawkeye was
going to die no no no I knew I wasn't
gonna die because you [ __ ]
spoil for me that Quicksilver dies in
this [ __ ] movie what is wrong with
you why would I want to know that that's
a lot [ __ ] up this one reason I didn't
believe he died but I like the way it
was kind of making it seem like he was
the one who was going to die yeah it was
clever but you know you do see some of
his leadership skills especially when
he's talking like Scarlet Witch that
sense of humor is always cool he felt
more necessary you know like as I was
always the big joke about Hawkeye's like
do they really need this dude and I'm so
happy to acknowledge that in the movie
when he acknowledges like they're there
a number of lines in there that make it
seem like you feel appreciated yeah as a
whole if you got his own solo movie we
probably appreciate him a lot more
easily yeah I guess it's harder to do
that cuz he doesn't have the superpowers
he I mean he's got heightened senses it
seems like I think each Avenger did
serve their purpose but what I found
interesting was that a lot of the main
focus was not given to the main four
Avengers over here like they put more
focus on Hawkeye in his personal life
then they gave Bruce Banner and Black
Widow a romance story they were focusing
on characters that didn't have their own
solo movies as opposed to before we were
like they all got their solo movies now
we want to see them all come together
yeah first I was a little let down by
that no I was thinking about it and I
was like yes each Avengers serve their
purpose Thor had his four
or figuring out the infinity stone crap
you know cap is the leader in love and
martial artists and then you know
everyone knows Tony starix and Bruce
banners I like that's all there but then
you get Quicksilver you get the Scarlet
Witch you get Hawkeye you get Black
Widow you get Mark Ruffalo because Hulk
didn't have a standalone movie in phase
two I feel like they're even kind of
just forgetting about face one oh I like
that because the problem is wouldn't you
do a sequel to The Avengers it's like
well we've already gotten so much story
about these main three dudes right here
yeah you know we got one Hulk story we
need to like focus on these other
characters now it would be hard to
actually get like ten [ __ ] characters
to have every one of them shine equal
yeah of course I mean an ensemble is
always tricky and this time around
they've added more characters and
there's more stuff going on it seems
natural that the focus would shift you
know and play two different Avengers
strong suits and stuff and it makes
sense that they would shift the
character focus of emotional storyline
because we know that three of main
Avengers and Hulk are gonna be fine yeah
it's like so it's like let's focus on
characters who might actually die yeah
you know because they don't ever don't
stand alone oh yeah or just who we don't
get to explore you know yeah because you
feel like it's more likely to happen
that way I think they need to start
killing off some main Avengers because
otherwise every time they get together
we're just gonna be like ash it's fine
oh yeah it's like they're always gonna
return again yeah or they have their own
franchise to go back to it takes away a
lot of fear this movie did a good job
making me wonder how they would defeat
Ultron but going back to the humor J
what I would like to talk about is that
scene when everyone's trying to pick up
Thor's hammer oh yeah I mean that whole
part is he I would watch a whole movie
about that it was a great [ __ ]
hilarious that's what I mean I wish I
had more like here's what I felt I felt
there was humor injected throughout the
film yes I wanted more fun like that
scene that's what I was trying to say
okay because I thought the first one had
a lot of that font there were still
jokes throughout age of Ultron but I
didn't feel that level of humorous fun
as much as I wanted it to I guess I mean
I don't mind them being different I was
laughing throughout this movie even even
times
when other people weren't as much so
like I thought there was a lot of fun
and he were mixed in sort of along the
way he was like Robert De Niro on Cape
Fear my favorite moment and that whole
picking up Thor's hammer scene was when
cap budged it yeah and then you see like
Chris Hemsworth
thank you playing of emotions yes
perfect that was perfect perfect and it
was just a cool scene I'm like the
Ultron shows up that's my brush but why
I really liked that scene is because it
teases my favorite moment out of that
whole film cuz that scene is just played
out like this is just for laughs as for
a chemistry and to see the avengers
bonding again what it is like
it totally is but then it becomes so
meaningful when they bring in my
favorite character from this film vision
vision was fantastic paul bettany did a
great job it's cool because you know
next level on this he plays voice-over
for so many years and then he has to
bring it to actual human form yeah and
he does it like perfectly oh yeah well I
mean the way he portrays vision and just
the dialogue they gave them like a lot
of gravitas yeah yeah and it was the
perfect film to introduce vision yeah
because it's the exact protagonist they
need to be equal to the antagonist yeah
you know like the whole time with that
hammer the whole point was you can't
pick it up if you ain't worthy yeah and
then when vision Greta cuz the whole
time they're like man Tony you created
created Ultron I don't know if I could
trust this dude you know like you [ __ ]
up badly what's the Z he's not gonna
[ __ ] up and it was perfect cuz the first
I didn't even think about it and then
when cap and Thor both notice and then
we all notice and it's like she's like
yeah it's like oh he's the worthy one to
save us so yeah that was awesome
incus the creation of vision was the
perfect way for Tony to get his
redemption oh yeah because Tony creates
Ultron with this goal in mind but he
totally [ __ ] up instead of letting him
fail and just have to defeat the bad guy
they let him solve it like the equation
that he's been trying
fix yeah so he solves it brings about
vision ultimate way to get redemption to
be like hey guys
I know I [ __ ] up and a lot of people
died including that Russian boy yeah I
make vision well yeah and it also gives
it makes that conflict make sense
because you know the other vendors are
still like not a now dude you've already
done this once don't do it again
and he's like no no I got it this time
and then to have that pay off is no
vision I have a vision of [ __ ] vision
they talk about death Quicksilver what
you didn't see me going ah came on Hawks
I really rigid on her a joke out of 10
more like 20 out of 10 this has really
talked about everyone's like what the
[ __ ] you know could you kill off
Quicksilver in the first movie now when
Quicksilver died I was bummed out
because it was like I was like man I'm
hoping those comments are all lies yeah
because I was like [ __ ] I like this
quick so great you know yeah totally
different from Days of Future past you
could compare all you want but I thought
this Quicksilver it was a better version
for what age of Ultron story was oh hell
yeah I mean he fits a lot better in this
universe yeah that iteration I mean
they're totally different characters
maybe they sure enough killed him off
because it was his first story and we
could have expanded it seen him in more
Marvel films but this other side is like
well this is really like more scarlet
witch's stories one that is his death
arguably is something that has an effect
on her and will drive her character
forward in a certain way yeah so it's
like though it is a bummer to see him go
too soon you know that death means a lot
to her and it's sort of marks a turning
point for her at the end of the movie I
mean most of the focus between the two
of them goes much more to her yeah I
mean especially because Ultron has heard
like do the whole mind manipulation [ __ ]
but features some great dream sequences
yeah those were cool I liked the
addition of those yeah from the very
first one every one of them was great
the production of it was Nina's very
artistic strange yeah brings just a
different visual flair to these movies
and it does add more that creepy
haunting vibe that I was like
really referring to which is not bad
people think I'm saying the drama is bad
so I was saying like a couple of
interaction moments I didn't find that
entertaining but the drama is really
good for they like adds to the intensity
it makes the fight scenes more rewarding
too yeah of course you know like a first
Avengers had a lot of like we want to
see these kinds of fights so let's turn
it an image that's perfect for that
first Avengers nothing's worth anything
if you don't care you know so it's like
that's what the drama goes to serve yeah
cuz then you see Scarlet Witch and she
uses all her powers and then even when
Hawkeye is like you step out that door
you're a [ __ ] Avenger [ __ ] yeah and
then she's Lee because we already got
like someone's being taken care of in a
hold of the franchise my first feeling
was man he didn't really get a rewarding
death he was just saving Hawkeye and
nimman Hawk I don't have like some
strong established relationship in any
form yeah it's so and he dies I'm like
[ __ ] then my second pot goes well if it
was gonna be a more important death it
might have been more obvious well yeah
exactly exactly but this is [ __ ]
Marvel you bring back anyone from the
dead suppose I mean he and he and cocci
both traded that line about not like you
I think he says something like that when
he's been shot ya didn't see that guy so
like you know they do have a little bit
of a payoff there they have a joke they
both really like that they love to call
back on Hawkeye you know goes to sleep
later on the romance between Natasha and
Bruce now the Tosh has kind of been
flirting with everyone's [ __ ] in these
movies yeah which is kind of a weird
like yeah I guess the desire to have a
romantic story on these movies but it is
kind of weird well what they normally do
a black widow is let's throw on some
sexual tension between her and a hero
this one they're like let's throw in on
romance with her Jan I'm gonna see a
different side and it is cool to see
like Bruce banners more sensitive side
but you know how Bruce is gonna be yeah
the whole you can't be you mean yeah but
if you give me mad that's when to
straight up domestic violence oh how
would they [ __ ]
no I brought this up in the Incredible
Hulk review hold on oh I don't think
that's gonna be a yes here anybody heart
rate too high he can't buck we'd love
that in phase one yeah so he has to [ __ ]
is the whole [ __ ] yes some people don't
like the romance between Bruce and
Natasha I don't mind it it makes sense
she can't conceive a kid he probably
doesn't want to conceive a kid unless
he's the Hulk
- that vagina come on hold can only have
sex if he's a hole yeah that's what the
solo films about it about him learning
how to you know do everyday stuff copies
its opening montage if I'm trying to
figure out how to like have sex again
it's just enough blending and like an
uplifting sort of indie you know dramedy
about a guy living in New York yeah
every time Natasha comes into these
movies I like more and more what they're
doing you know like you really get a
good glimpse into like maybe like the
kind of lifestyle she had as a little
girl and I thought that was really cool
because they're always hearing like she
has a traumatizing fucked-up past and
she was a bad person but now she's good
to actually see some of that like
childhood stuff was really interesting
yeah that was cool I like that you know
with the Hulk with the way his character
ends I like it made me go I want to see
his solo adventure afterwards but at the
same time I was like the same bulk story
what I liked about it was Bruce Banner
starts off like he's okay with being the
Hulk and then he goes back - yeah I
shouldn't be the whole Kenny Moore yeah
because of the opening like old that
opening to [ __ ] love that first 10
minutes just had a huge [ __ ] smile on
my face you know you got all that great
dancer back let's like the characters
are back we don't need a voice anytime
with them like having to assemble again
they got each other you know they're
gonna get back so just let them [ __ ]
get back together
couple of [ __ ] well that's a cool
thing about this movies you get the
sense that like since shield has sort of
dissolved a bit like now they're just
the Avengers and that's a standalone
organization yeah you know that's cool
to me they're what shield should have
been according to GAAP of course Hulk
Buster versus Incredible Hulk yeah that
was
pretty incredible and I hope busted it's
Iraq I was waiting for that Jeffy
imagine when Hulk comes they gooey green
you when you make the porno you know I
was white come and turn into the
marshmallow man from ghost bus but yeah
that was a bomb fly house a badass they
revealed like 15 minutes of footage from
that fire but that extra 10 min really
cool no not favorite from that fight was
when Tony was doing the [ __ ] punch
where they didn't and he's like stay
down stay down
where does he sit go to sleep sleep go
to sleep go to sleep go to sleep oh man
that's great what is the way that fight
ends to with like the Hulk getting up
out of the rebel like screaming at the
crowd and then just some you know like
from from out of frame and it shows that
the Hulk is pretty creative no matter
what trappings they gave him he's like
no get what I want when he becomes the
Hulk is a primal creature so just
whatever is there you know it's like
he's not dumb he's just the thoughts of
firing so fast and it's just this yeah
and Scarlet Witch I'm going back to her
yeah her fake accent bother me but I
still like the law what they do with her
character like you know like she's the
main reason things took a turn of events
everyone had a very clear defined goal
but then when she interfered people
started getting [ __ ] up
thought was like man you go my own and
then Bruce Banner was like they
shouldn't be the Hulk anymore
Black Widow was like I should go to
sleep because I'm very traumatized cap
was like I miss my [ __ ] she's so old
now
she has amnesia him everything whenever
I show I've been here like 15 times well
and they called that back beautiful yeah
it's like now I did that last time the
mind control thing already didn't like
yeah perfect oh yeah because I was
wondering when they if and when they
might have Nick Fury show up I know he's
on the poster so you gotta have him
somewhere but I like the way they used
him in this in a more like limited
capacity he comes in a good portion the
way through the movie after seeing so
many Avengers films were like he's or
like the lead up films where he's such a
prominent role is cool to kind of have
him be just a side character you know to
advise them yeah well it's different now
before it was like representative of
this huge secret organization yeah
now just a representative of good
there's a lone survivor yeah like it's
supposed to be dead so I actually think
it would be a cool Nick Fury standalone
movie yeah at this stage not when he's
like running shield like when he is on
his own hiding you know but that would
be a really cool Nick Fury I agree I
agree we are on the same page here dude
look at that I concur there were some
cool cameos in the movie too
it's weird like it almost works better
for me in this scenario whether you go
please take a bunch of little supporting
characters from all the standalone
movies then you put them on the Avengers
and it really does make the Avengers
feel like a whole big world yeah it does
and it feels less intrusive you don't
like to have you know rody and then
Falcon and a bunch of different people
show up to man they just don't know how
to write yeah the funny scene work he
doesn't do anything as crazy as these
guys and then he shows up for like five
and a half minutes to help out I wish
pal gonna show up in that I wish Falcon
would show he was quick he was cool and
Winter Soldier that would he was one of
my favorite parts of that whole thing
man he was really cool because he's
human but man does he have some serious
skill with that [ __ ] and the closing
scene the final the finale with the
Avengers headquarters oh yeah that was
really cool do you know like because now
it's the new shield in a lot of ways a
shield was creating a secret
organization led by Nick Fury of
superheroes but it wasn't like what
shield was capitalizing off yeah but
this Avengers is capitalizing off the
fact that we're trying to gather as many
heroes together as possible well now
there's a better sense of community
because it's not just Tony's building
anymore you know well that alone expands
the whole universe to many more options
because you could throw in like a
billion more Marvel characters into this
world now and the Avengers are
constantly switching in and out of here
yeah we need x-men in there
I thought the action it was better than
the last one yeah yeah EMF
[ __ ] no but this is about which
one is good and which ones not anymore
you know cuz now there's two we have to
decide what you can't like to jam like
over them if you like one more than the
other that means you hate the other one
you accent in this interpretation people
got from me only new [ __ ] is good no the
more I think about it the cooler it gets
and I sometimes fluctuate to thinking
it's better than the first one yeah
quite enjoy I don't know which one I
gotta go back and watch the first one it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
yeah it doesn't like them both in your
okay they're not one movie they're it's
like we don't need to go which one's
better like even if all age of Ultron is
not better that doesn't mean it's a bad
movie I still think it's a great film
yeah I mean there's it's it's a much
harder movie to stick the landing for
arguably because the first one just had
to do it right and this one has to live
up to so many things oh yeah all right
guys let's our spoiler review of
Avengers age of Ultron right if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
Jerry's playlist on this channel reasons
to GRE there he does movie reviews and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter
trying to get product placement here
yeah we would like product placement
from Snapple oh so now that I could get
on board with a lot of Snapple yeah I
like to you I do Snapple to me is the
best company ever I'm gonna get product
placement show your math I'm gonna get
product placement from them okay watch
here's the key every time before I [ __ ]
I drink a snap